all right I'm Trevor Noah and I'm in New
York shooting for GQ magazine the
funniest name for parts of the human
anatomy scrotum scrotum because it
sounds cute but it's not my favorite
scene ever from a movie just like the
most random thing you can shout out
whenever you want anywhere in the world
is obviously Scarface it's just that
moment we say hello to my little friend
and then you can use it for anything you
know you can use it in the streets you
can use it in the bedroom you can use it
anywhere say hello to my little friend
it's fantastic anyone could use that
Mickey Mouse could be using that whoo
all clear look my little friend who's
the funniest current world leader
Vladimir Putin because he's not funny
which makes him funny I was on the cover
of GQ South Africa so that was the lion
edition that was a very interesting we
do all our shoots in the bush that's
what we do so there's no flash
photography it's just the light of the
Sun very harsh lighting and you may get
eaten during the shoot that's what adds
to it all our pictures have a certain
flair to them it's real fear in those
shots everything comes to life and this
it gets killed which is of course part
of the allure